well thank you very much for having me
here thinks I'm kind of a newcomer to
this by informatics that would take a
few minutes to introduce my group to
know tell you where we come from so I
mean statistics and years my people come
from actually both fields statistics and
ye and city was there and car from a
group and this collaboration started
about four years ago one band bra was
part of ink code approached me suggested
collaboration with irvine urban who is a
balaji abl and peter vehicle was the one
who already made connection with brown
and high-end want to so i'm kind of
riding on their connection and working
on bass and so my group really for the
last 15 20 years engaged in high
dimension statistics machine learning
did a lot of sparse modern theory and
you can see that we had to using that
for this problem in big time i have been
also engaged in remote sensing and
computational neuroscience we also
borrow idea from there too so when we
started this we actually had a lot of
experience but not so much in genomics
although 15 years ago so i didn't do a
little bit physical mapping that's why i
heard of mike's work and then quickly i
disappear because it was so technology
driven and we saw good collaborators i
went to neuroscience so now with the
good collaboration kind of coming back
so that's how my group works and we have
theory people we have acronym people are
also people like sweeties than half of
their time in the wet lab so this is the
team it's one of the project i'll call I
think my favorite project now it's
really data some we have three teams of
people this is the IP aku co-lead urban
city with graduate student basically co
advised by urban we sit in the back will
answer all the hard questions and my
team and Suzanne occurs leveraged anelka
experiments and we have a team at ching
hai university computer scientists try
to help us scale out the computation
based on spark and the fiji so its
really three teams working together and
some of you actually have probably know
about this data HMO or have worked on
that more than I have oh when is here
who actually work on this earlier than
we did so this is a public data set
I produced by Suzanne occurs group of
the drosophila group at ABL instead of
different conditions experiment
condition different tissues is kind of
different tissue here too we have gene
expression data in ensue to kind of
embryo this is dress LMBO about full hot
stage for six or two or three hours and
there are other available data as well
to give the spatial information and also
you can kind of think of this location
it's kind of like different conditions
on rnc because we also try some data
seem to make sense to so primarily we
develop this platform hoping to have
other people also use it to support this
like enriched spatial old gene
expression data and the way we work is
that we usually take a problem I mean
we're kind of statistical so we like
general masters but we really drill into
a problem and were Chris polishes and
validated and then we kind of come out
as a gentleman 234 possible other
problem so so we first have finished the
first phase which is four years we have
first paper coming out is to really
validate what we do feel you know way
comfortable to to publish and this is
known to everybody here but I just want
to find out I do have different
experiments conditions but think of my
piece of location as like different
condition you can think of it's like a
different tissue too because they're
different organs there but it's all in
su 2 in the embryo
and this is a microscopic image which is
kind of you have a lot of processing
huge amount of image processing work
done before we go down the problem and
I'm not going to talk about that because
mainly buta other people work and
yourself allah for those of you who
probably all heard of yourself that you
solve people i work with tell me that
share 75% of genes with humans and yes
they i heard from down on that actually
the diabetes people have been studying
diabetes using drosophila model and also
some paper from sue last night so
hopefully it's a relatively inexpensive
model to study a lot of basic mechanism
hopefully will generalize across to a
higher beings and the data we're looking
at one terabyte they tell me they have
most of the genes seven thousand and we
kind of set up when we started probe the
project to see whether we can reproduce
its fate map which was obtained by laser
ablation old technology try to cut
things out to see which part is which
this different this is kind of the
purpose like a new road region and this
is more like god i forgot things like
that so we see that can we use our data
modern data high-throughput to figure
out the different regions can we figure
out these two genes interact or not for
me interaction this talk it's about
co-occurrence at this covariance it's
not just called currents covariant yes
particular spatial location and region
and i can see from other talks that
there can be different things
and the jeans I'll be talking about
today about 700 of them mostly
transcription factors because for the
early stage based on biology that most
of the genes correspond to transcription
factors and there's local cascading of
reactions happening they were workers
societies a dataset is existed and still
being added on for at least five seven
years and the lab them selfish papers
our human annotated data basically
located phonology morphology of the
tissues and then say which regions that
and a lot of work including urban's work
use that to do supervised learning okay
so we will go back to supervised
learning as a validation but in the
beginning we mulching and supervised
learning yeah meaningful many the one
thing I think design principle of for
the lab was spatial information rich and
heterogeneous can we take advantage of
that to figure out local gng networks
one prominent spatial information useful
for changing interactions the famous
captain network this german scientist
got the nobel prize in the fifth in the
90s for her work in the seventies most
of the drosophila teams of german
because she her life discovered many of
them is means giant you so this is a
like a schematic embryo the giant king
is here and also here it says that joy
means that if you knock out this gene
the embryo will become big or giant and
this is tailless if you knock out this
gene the embryo becomes paolas and this
to means the same gene and they play
different roles at different location
and in the anterior part inter ravished
krupal and here in Turkey knee and
tailors and hunchback so this is that
depends on where the genius I mean I'm
not really abolished so I try to explain
to institution in a way that the jeans
are like workers for the embryo
development stage the worker team up
to view different houses the different
houses are different organs so that's
what they do this is the fruit fly
embryo you can see the segmentation the
gap t know work is instrumental for
building these vertical divisions and
this is the human embryo you also have
the segmentation so that just give you a
sense that there's things to learn from
to push trip out to humans and we did a
lot of processing to go to 405 super
epistles and so that we have a data
matrix we can work with and there's
using the work from eric singh screw
from CMU to put them on the same your
lips also a lot of work was done so
that's the data we work within the talk
and just to show you a hunchback and
joint we know from the gap jean edouard
they kind of repressive each other look
a giant look at hunchback you probably
can visually move this piece here and
they fit pretty well so they are
repressive each other this is to show
you that our data does have information
to recover the the captain network right
because the spatial contingency
and this is another work to show that in
the drosophila literature people already
thinking about segregation Oh
segmentation for the embryo bits how
different organs will grow after the
different parts of the body and this is
just another mole recent work than the
biofeedback on the building block so
this is one slide of overview of the
teamwork which three teams coming
together the first step we did is
something we borrow from computation
your son Latin went to non-negative
matrix factorization and that is
decomposition and then we compute local
gene networks and then we do
recommendation for the lab we have some
early result of now care experiments our
share a little bit with you and then we
feedback loop and go back to do my
analysis and use spark and cg both open
source to be with the whole platform so
this is an iterative process of where I
people we're kind of in the middle the
statistic kind of computational but need
help from computer science you to the
release getting up
and if in terms of methodology the
contribution of this work i'm talking
about it really came from the stability
which have been advocating in this
diffuser and machine learning literature
which have seen in many talks people do
already doing that you procure of your
data in a sensible way and you want your
conclusion to be stable and it's very
easy to do and I think we can do at many
levels when I teach apply statistical HT
level course I can't you tell people for
classroom because depends on which one
you use you and always different rights
you should have conclusions robust to
the different method you choose so so
kind of these papers kind of overview
paper tying together some works for my
group and with my collaborators to post
that reproducibility the first step
which is easy to do is the sensible
perturbation could be adding noise could
be adding synthetic data could be just
bootstrap subsampling but has to be
contacts appropriate and that's what we
did here is actually a robustness
relative to random starting point for a
non convex optimization problem and work
really well so amazed adaalat
contribution I said we call stat for
stability non-negative native activation
and implicitly the two positivity
constraints actually it's huge a space a
constraint for our problem and we
started with our one constraint in the
end we didn't need it if we move to as
far as a positivity constraint
and we're hoping that this week all
principal patterns will play a role in a
lot of a romantic sighs as a basic
decomposition like what pgs played in
low dimensions for the dehumanization of
course we have additive ax t so that we
can look at things in the based on like
the heterogeneity and look at part by
part so that's the hope as I said when
been approached me and kind of
matchmaking me with urban fridge and I
was actually talking with my poster
computer vision Julian Morel about this
problem been approached me because he
recognized and more than I did actually
I like image data work on remote sensing
images and computational neuroscience
images and that's why he approached me
with this problem so they set upon local
networks and the first thing is we've
been working a lot the first v1 for
visual cortex is actually this cabral
like wavelet decomposition and this
cabal like seeing came up from data it
didn't come from mathematic formula
sometimes we do use that you have
patches and images and do sparse coding
those are the components that come up
this art like H detectors okay so that's
why we borrowed the idea cross from
computational neuroscience to statistics
I think that's the kind of the power of
statistic is actually we borrow from and
cross fertilize and we use that actually
work very well because the different
parts directly not by irvin and sue that
as meaningful by like two parts later we
migrated to non- extra factorization and
we get similar results but this is just
cleaner in practice so our fear we
actually still on the other version so
this is we remember i had 405 super
pistols you line them up as a big factor
doesn't matter i just have a fixed order
they have to match but we didn't take
into any spatial contiguity for this
decomposition
right so you have we have like 400
something vectors and now now thank you
factorization say that we want to
decompose it into columns of a
dictionary matrix with a coefficient
matrix the basic postulating that each
these gene images is edited summation of
these different parts and with different
low loading coefficients and because i
think the team's the genes do work
together respecting the physical
boundary like pre Alden regions you end
up with spatially coherent sub-regions
an in higher dimensional later stay we
might have to put some special concern
but this just fall out we didn't put any
constraints panel comes in here and it's
because the way the genes work due
respect these boundaries because the
building things together to have
different organs come out later and this
is earlier than mythology can help
biologists to say you know the different
texture coming out this is basically go
beyond what the current human vision
technology can see in terms of organs
this is we called pre organ regions and
we have positivity country on both the
dictionary matrix and the coefficient
matrix this is all very high dimensions
so if you think about in dimension D the
positivity constraint give you 1 over 2
to the power of D like fraction of the
whole space so it's pretty strong
constraint and therefore that's why we
didn't need l1 anymore on top of that so
positivity country our work Mouse Bell
Labs also a network tomography problem
we started with emm all kinds of things
and later we just use a positivity
constraint and work really well so it's
a very strong constraint why
swain leads the sparse solution what do
you mean by sparse and wise why is what
what is the connection between
positivity and sponsors the positivity
to be exact we have a lot of small
coefficients for the a so that's what I
mean and we later I cheated a little bit
later did do another thresholding yeah
but you can directly to our one on these
two right you can add I'll one and then
but it's just this very strong give you
a small coefficient we did another round
of Las to type of thing
so the methodology contribution we made
it to to this work is actually using
stability by across different initial
values so for this problem if you look
at D&A together it's non convex but if
you condition a tea to optimize over D
that's comebacks and for the other
direction as well so we randomly
selected the original data as the
starting value for the D right so one
big problem a lot of this type of
classroom this is very close related is
how many dictionary you need or how many
principal patterns you want to have
that's why we use stability so we start
with two random starting points a 21-10
you buy random images from your data you
start with them as d and just alternate
and minimize and then with some
convergence criteria you look at the
final results and you allow permutation
to match so we use correlation for each
principle pattern you'll find for two
runs you find the best match find the
best correlated and you do 1 minus that
that give you the dissimilarity if it's
one they are completely similar you find
your match ok so this is the you can
call a mari type amari have worked on or
anything is using this and this is just
making symmetric and then you look at
that dissimilarity you find 21 as the
minimum and you said 22 is pretty good I
agree actually look at 22 1 principle
pattern got split into two and we did a
lot of stability analysis too we've
followed everything through four 22 to
make sure the conclusion don't change so
every stag we made kind of arbitrary
choice we follow through a few steps to
make sure that we're not just reading
off that arbitrary choice yes
you're looking at the tea not looking at
a because we're now estimating da right
here you go back to the data right you
try to decompose da right if you look at
the a that's fitted value we need more
than that that would be a prediction if
you want to do prediction that's a
different game but we want to interpret
these so that's why I wanted is to match
it's different it's different so you
have to decide on the metric for our
interpretation we want to individual DS
to be interpreted that's why so you
could if you want to do some prediction
of smoothing then you might want to look
at some other people who did you
actually look at that so it's very
problem specific how you devise your
stability metric depends on the task
yeah good question and these are
actually we learned that non-negative
matrix area had been used in Buttonville
man you remember we came from
computational neuroscience and by the
way they used it was different they
usually do the dictionary and use it as
featured for clustering and we're really
interested in interpreting the
dictionaries but very much you know and
they didn't look at this or instability
because their interest is forecasting
and they have something based on
clustering for stability depends on the
goal
and just to give you a sense give you
some confidence on what we do here is
sensible we start we do the simulations
of famous swimmer data simulation from
one of the early papers to analyze
non-negative matrix actor seizure
mathematically donna hahn studdin they
have 16 generator patterns like
different limbs of a swimmer and you put
them together randomly you get different
swimmer postures and of course we nailed
it down just like that right that's just
to give you a sense that so we did some
throughout your work visit the two
things important here one thing is so
called the in coherence of the different
elements imagine that if t1 to call them
on top of each other there's no way you
can separate them based on linear
decomposition but if there is only one
of them you know your true you have a
chance to separate them right because
you know needed the company so the
sparsity and incoherence are both good
if you're talking though because we are
looking at the under determining case
you have to have no problem separate
them a little correlation is okay as
long as the sparsity is there to help
you so for us the correlation we're
actually digging into it in simulations
and the theory is not exactly matching
it with the practice that we're going
there but basically we're now too bad in
early development stage because things
are growing from different part and out
overlapping as hard as later and later
there's a 3d problem because these
little animals are 3d and went in
looking in the flat view or projection
so that's what we got with that
stability driven non-negative matrix
factorization we got 21 we call
principal patterns and I'm from
mathematics as an undergraduate so I
loved it is like the vertical coordinate
system and the horizontal collagen
system it's pretty amazing but this
one's i just say i want something else
right but this this you lie I love this
like x and y right telling where to go
and there's some odd bits right not
everything go that way but the major
part are pretty nicely lined up vertical
and horizontal and now we met with a
very careful job really you know this is
a schematic map but we do the best we
can we did them as much as that you lips
old and put on top and mad that's how we
have this half circle because this one
mask and a half into the grey it's like
York half into the mesoderm right this
is half for God and the purple is
neurogenetic genic a region right this
is like stem cells and this is posterior
Midgard so you can see that all the
early regions are food and shelter and
some brain right that's basic what's
going on you know I love skin
development you have the gas system
developing and beginning of newer
systems
so then this was what we are here
actually maybe two years ago will read
the network and the next question
answers so first we wanted to do knock
our experiments and that just took a
long long long time so we had to publish
this work before that completely finish
and we asked ourselves how do we
validate what we find we like it but is
it enough we look at the patterns look
meaningful come it pushes harder to use
it give more evidence this is useful d
conversation so the first thing I don't
remember exactly the order one thing we
end up doing is that we can characterize
genes accounting the different principle
pattern so you look at my region and you
can construct correlations in network
and ten to twenty five percent of the
genes in drosophila even they know that
genes are called the computational genes
so they don't know functionality well oh
wow so and then we can do prediction and
then we can do a local team network
instruction so let me go very fast so
this is attempt to do that we do the
different see where they express
themselves so you can see this vlog
where am I interior women to to the folk
art and this part I think related to the
hint cuts memory card so you can now
keep functionality right and twenty
percent of the genes this blue part are
computational jeans and you can also
look at crosstalk right whether they are
close together to share my jeans for the
different regions and so forth and this
is go back to compare with pistols and
the thing out bullying work down sparse
base vectors we get similar prediction
resign by in terms of interpretation the
piece of why doesn't really interpret
just oscillated bits and the print the
base factors give negatively kind of
values that's why so altogether we like
what we have done because it's positive
and also sparse and give similar
prediction okay so let me just jump to
the gene network so we burn back to
captain network we have 40 pages of
supplemental material
so there's a lot of detail work I'm not
telling you because you have to map
things together we basically reproduce
each other out of the links for the
graph G network using our methodology
and for the so the lab has been doing
Chris Burke case nine experiments we end
up with faulty experiments and let me
just show you some results so we have to
also do which with up string which is
downstream and this is knocking out a
particular computational gene the number
is pretty big and this is a wild type
for this pair routine called ftz and
this is the wiretap this is mutant and
you can see that the head is allocated
and we have a lot of work hard to put it
together so the Y type is the purple and
you have a little darker green is the
overlap and you have the mutant seem to
suggest that on the population level
there is bigger longer had a span for
the mutant and there's also some
evidence we think we know this is
definitely important because before
hatching about 16 hours oh the embryos
died but we're told you can now
published paper said because they died
you have to say why I died and it looks
like it seems the neural system then
nervous cord is messed up and we're in
the middle of doing more experiments
with suits lab and try to really prove
the case that is we find the genes
important and we try down are in sick
you can see the principal patents it
seems to be meaningful to but we haven't
really gone further than that and we
like to be able to try as in church
group about two years ago now supposed
to have a technology which can similarly
nitrogen expressions for thousands of
genes and that will be great because we
won't have matching problem and we like
to be able to contribute the human
genetics if anything funding agency
wants you to do that and
is ordered by different organizations
and this is the paper I disappeared
online at PS thank you
shuriken yeah as he said the work is
pretty similar to what we did a few
years ago in terms of the idea of
decomposing the spatial patterns yeah
tensions what we did at the time was to
put the sparsity on the factor loadings
with the idea that each gene will only
be controlled by a small number of
factors because we I hopefully these
factors are present positive and
negative transcription factors yeah so
you don't have a sparsity constraint
like that right the early version with
this fast coding is very similar and we
find out with just the two positivity
country give very similar result well
first version from computational
neuroscience was very similar you kind
of took the Beijing margin and we didn't
quite know when we started actually a
world later we discovered at least we
you know the people maybe maybe urban
Dubai maybe mathematics he didn't
realize but later we definitely
recognize that and that's why we compare
yeah slightly different versions of the
decomposition obviously the other thing
that we noticed I think it's an
interpretation part I think that's where
we differ we part our way a bit yeah we
found helpful and that's what people
also seen when they used you know we
already stole this idea of course from
other people before us and so from
expression analysis for instance when
you do these decompositions often you
end up with factors that are really
useful because they represent your
experimental artifacts and biases like
for instance we had some that
represented just you know blurry
outlines of the embryo because some of
the pictures are out of focus or you
would have lighting differences it's
always a bit lighter than the bottom and
so we wouldn't have these factors that
soaked up the artifacts you also see
that because we found that pretty
helpful I think we did a lot of
screening probably for the image before
we went in right yeah so we probably
avoided that because we really want an
interpretation and for the local gene
network I agree the beginning part very
similar but then i'll go with small no
prediction we did a prediction to
compare by small like to build local G
network yeah but I think we did a lot of
menu human screening for those bad
images because we we threw
thing at it and the kitchen sink so we
didn't even filter out whether the
embryos were in the pre-processing and
the correct orientation and everything
it was did we did predict we did pretty
careful pre-screening I think if we
didn't we all see similar thing we're
probably gonna have very weird parts I
was I believe that yeah and there's also
you know like deep learning all that
stuff yeah so did you the input of your
algorithm are just six gift jeans right
no no we started with 405 jeans I just
concentrated to compare with the gravity
network yeah we didn't just use that we
have lots of lost computational jeans
like twenty percent with the
computational jeans